jacques années maintenant et il est moon
c'est bon pour toi
aurélie qui est très étonnant c'est que
vous êtes un habitué des plateaux de
télévision voie relativement souvent si
d'ailleurs moi aussi mais moi je suis
pratiquement tous les jours et pourtant
vous êtes parfois mal à l'aise et vous
avez déclaré j'aimerais pouvoir parler
de mon travail sans être coincé entre
deux rubriques à la con sans passer
après un sujet sur les nouveaux slip en
hollande
oui bon c'est vrai que c'est pas
toujours c'est pas très valorisant
d'être à terre par exemple devant un
animateur
oui je me considère comme un artiste je
fais un certain travail
j'estime que être comme ça à plat ventre
devant les sur les plateaux de télé
c'est pas mon style d'accord moi je
j'estime que j'ai une certaine fierté
jamais au grand jamais je me mettre à
genoux devant toi par exemple encore du
grand n'importe quoi autant c'est un
artiste que j'espère de talent en tout
cas c'est ce que les gens me me renvoie
comme aux logements qui seront rien
qu'en maintenant je pense donc elie
semoun ce soir on va parler de votre
travail
on va parler des slips pour le travail
on va parler de la genèse de votre acte
aura elie semoun
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette
petit ami ou bien vous brosser les dents
et les fêtes de bourg est donc à 10 ans
elie semoun vous écriviez déjà de deux
petits pots album est un peu plus à
l'aise mais faites ce que vous voulez du
mal à me sentir à l'aise et vous sur la
table voilà là comme ça je me sens mieux
vas-y toi le parlement voilà très bien
comment ça va ça va comment ce que
j'étais toujours j'étais un peu crispé
au départ oui et comme j'avais des
problèmes en famille familialement g
j'ai toujours voulu exprimer d'une façon
théâtrale chose que je ce que je voulais
dire c'est à dire pour moi là pour moi
là la réalité a toujours été difficile à
comprendre mais l'homosexualité par
contre j'aime bien quand on a décidé ce
cas soirée le sénat ce qu'on va parler
de ton travail quels cas et surtout à
temps parce que je me sens pas à l'aise
là je met comme ça l'impression d'être
l'athlète du mois affectant un joli cul
ouais bien c'est donc évident semoun on
va parler de la genèse de votre acte
aura si un accord est bien puisque si si
c'est une émission culturelle donc à 10
ans vous écriviez déjà de petits poèmes
oui j'étais déjà à thales gt gt déjà en
effet
attiré par tout ce qui était président
tout ce qui était artistique c'était
j'avais le désir déjà d'être d'être un
artiste est ce qu'on pourrait dire qu'à
l'époque vous étiez elie semoun un
artiste en miniature oui j'étais un mini
artistes et aussi bien physiquement que
qu'intellectuellement non mais c'est
vrai je tombais amoureuse régulièrement
il était tombé amoureux de ma prof de
français et ça n'est absolument pas
marché
j'avais 11 ans et qu'elle devait avoir à
peu près 40 ans j avais écrit des poèmes
elie semoun à 15 ans vous étiez déjà sur
scène et ça me permettait à fait comme
je branlée pas grand faim je faisais pas
grand chose on peut dire branlée ici je
suis oui oui oui je pense avec toi donc
je ne foutais pas grand chose mais
j'avais cette excuse auprès des profs
d'être un petit peu artiste donc il me
passait un peu les les choses quoi moi
là il a 19 ans à 19 ans elie semoun
vous rejoignez la troupe de roger louret
les baladins en agenais
vous rencontrez suite on la connaît
on la connaît basculer toutes les tous
les médias ça fait un petit peu ce qui
s'est passé avec la personne de couleur
je suis toi la connaissent pas soit
vraiment non non pas vont jouer donc on
est vraiment face à face comme ç'avait
voudrais qu'on fasse tous les deux une
expérience de télépathie ouais je vais
te poser une question oui si chic mans
oui et tu va me répondre
attention voilà jamais à bord n'ont
jamais facilement mais avec une fille
oui
ah oui alors qu'en france on s'entend
incroyablement bien
c'est peu de temps moi je vais mal à
quelque chose d'aussi way 23 quand même
dans la journée non le soldat bien alors
là on m'a parlé de roger louret donc les
baladins de l'agenais muriel robin tout
ça les débuts et alors ce qui est
incroyable c'est que aujourd'hui vous
travaillez toujours avec roger louret
vous êtes une incroyable fidélité suffit
de l'amitié c'est pas mal quand même
comme sentiments vous voulez vous dire
quelque chose à roger louret je crois
que c'est important pour vous ce soir de
lui de lui didier rocher
je sais que tu ne regardera pas cette
émission non mais si jamais il ya des
gens des amis à toi qui regardent cette
émission que toi même je voudrais dire
et je crois que l'ag
j'ai un gros plan je voudrais dire que
je t'apprécie énormément en tant qu'être
humain et que tu m'as apporté tout ce
dont tout ce dont je rêvais hormis
évidemment ce que tu sais bien alors
elie semoun vous avez repris en octobre
votre tournée avec votre dernier
spectacle est d'ailleurs vous êtes
demain à marseille le 27 à arcachon le 2
décembre à créteil le 3 à issy les
moulineaux le 6 à poitiers et le 16 au
bataclan
c'est très important parce que c'est une
soirée au profit de solidarité sida
c'est complet déjà donc je remercie les
gens qui ont acheté leurs places
ouais ils vont faire une bonne action et
on fait en effet les exquises et moi je
suis un petit peu ému une façon pour moi
d'évaluer un petit peu c'est le cri
primal
alors ce spectacle a été captée à
l'olympia en juin
j'avais pas faire tout ça en une année
vous avez dit olympia 7 ha oui bien sûr
mais en même temps alors on y retrouve
toutes vos obsessions elie semoun tous
vos personnages toufik qui est
originaire de malgré tout toujours
originaire de magog vicky fédé qui fait
un questionnaire de sondage pour vous
j'essaie de parler à des mains fetwa ces
deux puis on a une clause qui veut pas
répondre de la traite d'enculé lui des
vases et pourquoi tu me regardent comme
ça et j'ai peu quand tu m'agresses comme
ça enfin bref c'est toujours un petit
peu énervé toufik il ya kevin à 1 alors
kévin assure un classique moi je vous
dis ma fille à l'école
c'est tous les jours oui kevin est
devenu un personnage de la société
française
vous avez inventé quelque chose c'est
une petite adolescente et qui parle
pendant des heures au téléphone voilà
copine je connaissais la vraie vivre
j'en ai deux à la maison et alors jeanne
calment vous a inspiré un sketch ouais
paix à son âme d'ailleurs je crois bien
les décédés ah bon elle a mis du temps
mais bon non mais en fait oui c'est le
gers catch au début du spectacle
c'est sur une maison de retraite ouais
et ça m'a été inspiré en voyant cette
magnifique émission qui s'appelle strip
tease bien sûr où il y avait un
reportage sur les vieux et est envoyé
une infirmière qui dessert comme des
merdes
on n'a pas mangé ce matin ou pas ça va
gueuler à six mois je vous ramène dans
la chambre
petite laiterie sera une chaise roulante
avant sa série des ses pattes et sur la
mise en scène c'est comme ça voilà